[Music]
good day everyone
my name is john mills i'm a senior staff
scientist
with vmware u today i'm going to be
discussing with you the impact of aoec
for cannabis labs
and lab validations so
what will you learn today what are we
going to talk about who is aoac
and what is the role of aoac how does
aoc ensure and impact cannabis science
and safety
what is the value of aoec certification
for the cannabis industry and you
what does this mean for you in the
cannabis industry
and how does aoc impact state required
validation so first who is aoac
aoc basically establish establishes
standard methods of analysis these
standard methods of analysis
impacts health and safety and they are
globally recognized
if you look at the aoec webpage they
have some information on their legal
name their legal name is aoec
international the long form name is
association of official analytical
collaboration aoac
international and their new tagline has
evolved into
in food and agriculture we set the
standard
the organization name has evolved
throughout the years
and we will discuss this further in the
presentation
there are three main programs the
official methods program
the research institute and proficiency
testing
of note with the official methods
program
oma methods are recognized in the u.s
code of federal regulations
and they are legally defensible in court
worldwide
taking a look at aoec's mission
as a leader of analytical excellence
here we see
international advances product safety
product integrity
and public health by bringing together
members organizations
and experts dedicated to developing
and validating standards methods and
technologies
of global relevance
going back and looking at the aoc routes
in product safety aoac initially began
as the association of official
agriculture
chemists in 1884.
federal and state departments of
agriculture through the bureau of
chemistry
initially was formed to standardize
methodology to be used for
composition of fertilizers by state
laboratories formed
the original aoc this was directed by
harvey washington-wiley
who wrote the 1906 law to begin the u.s
food and drug administration
fda through a number of government
reorganizations the food and drug
administration came into being as a
result of the f of the food drug and
cosmetic
act of 1938 it came separate
the aoc was housed within the fda and
became the association
of official analytical chemists for the
next 40 years
only government chemists could become
members
in the 80s membership evolved and
included microbiologists food science
scientists professionals in 1991
association of official
agriculture chemists legally changed its
name to aoec
international association of analytical
communities
has been used to encompass all the
scientific disciplines
involved in aoec's work
so here's some additional details
regarding aoec and
its current activities we talked about
the main focus
of aoac is standard developments we have
two different programs for that
standard methods performance
requirements smpr's which we will talk
about quite a bit during this
presentation
official methods of analysis also
if you look at government and
organization there is a membership
elected board of directors and there's
also official methods board
for membership it's around 3000
individual member scientists
organizational affiliates 16 global aoc
sections
multiple analytical communities there's
awards and recognitions which are given
uh at the annual meeting each year which
includes going back to the founder of
the harvey wiley
award for laboratories
there is uh credited laboratory
proficiency testing program there's also
laboratory audit
laboratory auditing that is available
the alacc guidelines which is
accreditation guidelines for
laboratories this is aoec
accreditation guidelines for
laboratories is also
available alacc is a multinational group
of experts from a varied scientific
disciplines and industries and part of
aoc's technical division
or laboratory management or tdln
three publications from aoec that's
official methods of analysis of aoec
international there's around 2 800
methods in the
official methods of analysis there's a
journal of aoec
international and also in inside
laboratory management
magazine we also have the research
institute which is a division
of aoec that's where we have validation
protocol development
performance test and method
certification and official methods of
analysis program when it is harmonized
with the ptm and we'll go through this
quite a bit later in the presentation
so this is a representation of how aoec
fits into product safety for really any
industry
there are multiple layers to product
safety within a manufacturer
if you look at the graph on the left you
see a
manufacturing process on the outer ring
you go into hazard the hazard analysis
critical control points from their
critical control point and hazard
evaluation
and then at the center is
of this is analytical methods
this is where aoac comes in aoec helps
prioritize
analytical needs creates programs such
as cast
which we'll talk about quite a bit to
develop smpr's
validates methods for those smpr's these
methods are then published and available
to the industry so in the end the
industry will have validated fit for
purpose methods that they
can be confidently implemented
so here is a world picture of how aoec
leverages the power of many aoec uses
its global network to gather
stakeholders and
experts with the mission goal of
providing fit for purpose methods
as discussed in the previous slide this
map details the locations of aoc
stakeholders
and aoec sections throughout the world
so as you can see in this really quick
snapshot that a
that aoc is represented nicely worldwide
so how does aoc influence cannabis
safety or science and safety this is
through uh the cast firstly i would say
that casp is an a
fantastic example of how this how
abc influences cannabis and that stands
for the cannabis analytical science
program
as detailed here cass was a forum where
the science of hemp and cannabis can be
discussed in cannabis standard methods
developed
the cast group has been working very dil
diligently
on standard methods development and have
created several which we will discuss
more in the next slide
also experts in science and validation
aoc and cast
have been able to bring together kansas
experts validation experts and
technology experts to develop
critically needed standards for cannabis
a little bit more on casp if you look at
the scope and the objectives
courses develop smpr's for cannabis and
hemp extend a call
for methods for each of the completed sp
smpr's
and panel and expert review panel to
review candidate methods with the goal
of delivering consensus-based first
action
and final action official methods you
see
below the different working groups you
have microbiological contaminants
chemical
cannabinoids training in education and
also proficiency testing which we know
is important for the cannabis industry
i actually pulled this information off
of the aoc webpage aoec.org
there is a section under scientific
solution tab where you can find more
info on cast if you'd like to research
for yourself
what does aoec bring the cannabis
industry so firstly method testing
validation
third-party independent evaluation of
methods is very important
reliable analytical test methods we
talked about fit for purpose
these aoc will allow you to have fit for
purpose
methods which meet your needs and what
the industry needs also
and again ensuring science and safety
this is a rigorous validation of
analytical methods and gives you
confidence moving forward with those
methods
and at the end of the process this
collaboration
this is what we want to accomplish
methods that help protect the industry
consumers and products
so the smpr performance requirements
here is just a quick overview i have a
couple slides on this just
just to show you the process again
smpr's articulates a community's
analytical method need
fit for purpose again build on the
fitness for purpose
a very detailed description of the
analytical requirements
includes method acceptance requirements
include study designs
for measuring analytical performance
used to qualify methods for aoc approval
and these are published as a standard
you can go onto aoec.org
and pull these up they are open to the
public
this process has been especially
critical for the cannabis
industry as there were no available
standard methods to compare to for
validations and verification studies
cast group has been able to collaborate
and create the yardstick
for which any method must be compared to
and produce equivalent results
so another quick overview of the
scm-smpr process
the draft in smpr is created by a
working group
for cannabis that will of course be cast
the stakeholders review
and comment so after the working group
develops
smpr they're sent out for comment after
the comments come back the stakeholders
review that
you have a consensus consensus on the
draft standard
and then the final standard is prepared
for publication again you can see that
on the aoec webpage if you go to the
cache tab so on that caps tab on the aoc
i did pull off the list of standard
method performance requirements that the
cast group has been working on
you see there's two on cannabinoids
detection of aspergillus
detection of salmonella species
detection of sugar toxin producing e
coli
and determination of heavy metals
there's also a draft smpr for yeast and
mold enumeration that has been
sent out for comment you can see by
looking at this the cast group has
definitely been busy
one other program i did want to
highlight before we get into some
specifics
regarding ayc validation processes is
the
emergency response validation or the erb
the erv validates existing ptm approved
methods for new foods involved in
emerging
product safety crisis this was initially
the goal of the erv just to validate ptm
current ptm approved methods but aoc has
expanded that to
new ptm's and a good example of that is
the
the covet environmental erv that
that happened in 2019 which provided a
ptm approval for methods which
did not currently have a ptm approval
it's also a nice program because it's
fast-tracked
this can take less than three months
we'll talk about the timing of the other
programs later in the presentation but
this can take less than three months
three months sir aoec
arranges the preparation and
distribution of the test samples
they provide step-by-step support
each successful candidate method is
granted a certificate
of validate and then the results are
published in inside laboratory
management the journal of aoc
and on the aocri website again that
anyone can can access
and pull that information off these
projects are normally determined by aoec
management based on
global crisis or gaps in food commodity
safety testing
and this um this program was actually
recently employed by aoc
for an erv in cannabis and that's the
use for yeast and mold enumeration
let's talk just a little bit about aoec
evolution
and the oma program and the research
institute
so the official methods of analysis
program
actually initially was not designed for
commercial methods
aoec international developed the
performance tested methods
program for those test kit manufacturers
created the aoc research institute to
run the ptm
program so ptm programs specifically
program specifically to evaluate and
certify commercial test kits
and this allows a harmonized approach
with
a ptm and an element and we'll talk
about this just a little bit
later this is an efficient process and
appeals to the industry the reason it
appeals to the industry
is that prior to the research
institute and performance testing
methods if a test kit manufacturer
or anyone wanted to have an official
methods analysis they would have to go
through a pre-collaborative study first
and then the collaborative study we will
go through this information a little bit
later
but the ri in the ptm allows you to have
a certificate
almost like midway through the process
so you can have a certificate before you
go to official methods of analysis
it also allows you to have an approval
or certificate if for some reason you
may not be able to have enough
collaborative labs
so it's a nice middle point that gives
you a ptm number
you know gives you a proof source and as
it's mentioned here it is profitable to
aoc
this is a real quick snapshot of
everything that goes into an
aoc validation and we'll talk about all
of these inclusivity
exclusivity matrix study stability
and robustness the core of the
validation
is definitely the method comparisons
comparison study
the remainder of the validation we go
back to inclusivity exclusivity
shelf ruggedness etc are all still very
important however the method comparison
is where a method will demonstrate that
is equivalent or better
than a reference method here's a quick
snapshot of what that looks like you
spike
matrix and you test both the alternative
method and the reference method
for cannabis this would be compared to
an smpr that came
out of the casper so more information on
the matrix study itself
a selection of matrices associated with
the pathogen
which makes matrices are most important
to the industry
for cannabis this is this is of course
would be
flower and hemp other matrices can be
added after initial approval
via matrix extension if needed we
probably will see this in the cannabis
industry as more and more matrices
become important
natural contamination is always
preferred however at times it can be
challenging so artificial contamination
is permitted
which strains are important to an
industry for cannabis
this is a little difficult at the moment
but data are being collected daily from
from canvas laboratories and other
experts
we will know more at some point
competing flora
is important to include competing
organisms will they normally be present
in addition to the target organism
this could potentially be important for
cannabis for sure just because we know
that there is a significant vital burden
with
with flour in him
and lastly fractional results this
is artificial artificial contamination
at a level where only
25 to 75 percent of the samples are
positive
with either method this theoretically
ensures that some samples will be
inoculated with only a single cell
pathogen screening methods need to
demonstrate that one cell can be
recovered and
detected per test portion that is
critical
here's an example of matrix study
workflow
the validations for cannabis will be a
little different because they are paired
however
this will give you a good overview of
what is normally executed
a product sample is spiked again you
will have a fractional or high level
the candid method will be tested on that
test portion
in parallel with the reference method
you'll perform the assay the candidate
method confirmation
for the candidate method enrichment you
also do a secondary enrichment or an
extended enrichment
and then from that you will do a
reference method for confirmation
and then this is compared to another
test portion which
completely followed the reference
method for that assay or target
so a little bit closer look at both ptm
and oma what is needed what is required
what is normally done
here we see performance tested ptm
methods
you need to have one independent
laboratory
and for each matrix you test 20
replicates at low spike to led we talked
about fractional those need to be at the
fractional level so 25 to 75 percent
of samples are positive five high
spike level replicates and five
uninoculated when we move to the alma
this is a multi-laboratory study a
minimum of 10 labs we normally do
at least 15 because you're looking at
you need 10
good data points pre-req for this
is either a ptm or a pre-collaborative
study
the collaborative study is an interlab
reproducibility
same spiking crack criteria as a ptm but
there are fewer replicas just more
overall data points because you're
looking at multiple laboratories
so a little bit more about an oma
validation process and we talked about
how
the oma process have has evolved because
at one point
you had to do a pre-collaborative
followed by your collaborative you
didn't have the choice to do the ptm
again which is a midpoint
you didn't get a certification at that
midpoint
so if we go back to the old school
pre-collaborative studies performed by
one laboratory that's a contract
laboratory
all matrices claimed are evaluated at
that lab
and you know again a difference differs
a little bit
is that if you follow harmonize that
would need to be
an independent laboratory phase two
is the interlaboratory collaborative
study so multiple laboratory that
follows exactly what we talked about
before if you went from a ptm to an
almost a little bit different and you
can go direct bmw has done that in the
past where you skip the ptm process you
collect pre-collaborative data and go
directly to the normal so it's it can be
done it still is done it matters on
if you want the certificate and
timelines etc
more information on the performance test
and methods
we talked about each of these just a
little bit before
inclusivity exclusivity is required
method comparison
you need to test at least 10 products
for a variety of foods
since we're talking about cannabis i
wonder if we may discuss with aoec about
changing that
to a different term right now that is
what they would call a variety of foods
for your performance claim
and then you need to determine the
correct reference method of course for
cannabis we'll be talking about it some
prs
you need to demonstrate ruggedness this
is looking at
package insert parameters just outside
of what is in your packaging
insert to demonstrate that your system
is rugged
stability is shelf life you need to
provide data to demonstrate your shelf
life
and on top of that is that do you see
any variations when you look at multiple
lots
at the independent lab it's just a
single laboratory
and a minimum of one product tested at
that single lab
closer look at inclusivity this
is being able to demonstrate that an
assay has the ability
to detect target analyte from a wide
range of strings
so you need to test a minimum of one
hundred different stereotypes for
example for salmonella that's out of the
greater than twenty two hundred zero
bars
and a minimum of 50 for all or other
organisms
exclusivity you need to demonstrate that
there's no interference with your assays
with non-target organisms
and that's with a minimum of 30 isolates
now there is always a balance between
sensitivity and specificity
when you talk about near neighbors and
different
different types of assays the priority
will be given to sensitivity there
official methods of analysis we we did
talk about this just a little bit
you can either do a harmonized approach
with a ptm
or pre-collaborative but if you did the
pre-collaborative study
you do need inclusivity exclusivity
method comparison
normally we would we would have about 15
to 20 different products
and compared to a reference method we
have usda fda and iso
listed here but for cannabis it would
definitely be in the s prs
and then go to the collaborative study
again 10 labs minimum
a minimum of one product and then a
reference method
so how long do these normally take
if you look at official methods of
analysis
this is normally 12 months for approval
aoc research institute is six months for
ptm approval and if you do the harmonize
approach again where you would get a ptm
first and then move to the noma
that's normally 12 months i will say
though that aoec
has made the focus to decrease these
times
and i think if we went back and looked
in the last two or three years all of
these times are going to be decreased
because they did
put there was a huge focus in dropping
these
so i'm not sure these are quite accurate
because aoc does a good job of
turning everything around and the
volunteers also do a great job with that
we talked previously about some of the
information that you can get off of the
aoec
web page and they also have a nice
function that you can go in and search
all of the aoec
ptm validated methods so if you go into
the aoec ptm
tab and there is a searchable area
i had that pulled up here this is just a
screenshot from their webpage
and you can search based on the analyte
to the matrix the manufacturer of the
test kit the kit name
or the the ptm certificate number the
license number
so here's an example i went into the
website and i searched for cannabis and
here are the three
methods that came up that are currently
aoc ptm approved that's the genome
salmonella the genome
ehec or stack and the genophagia's pro
so let's go back to some of the
questions that we had at the beginning
of the presentation is that why is aoec
important we talked about leveraging the
power of many
aoec unites industry academia and others
there are a lot of great resources in
all of these different aspects that we
can bring in
and help each other and create methods
standard methods
smpr's working groups etc
established method testing validation we
talked about that
a key role of aoc
in the end aoac confirms
reliable analytical test methods
and of course that that then circles
around to ensuring safety of consumers
and this impacts public health
throughout the globe
going through aoac working with aoec
closely why
why is there value for companies like
like my company bmru
so aoc provides a rigorous
third party independent which is
important validation
of all of our methods when we have aoc
approvals
it gives an immediate level of
confidence for our users
our customers our potential customers
it also helps our customers when they
move toward isil accreditation for a
laboratory
there are some regulatory agencies and
programs within those regulatory
agencies that require
an aoec approval
it's also nice that an aoec approval
gives us a data package gives us proof
sources
so when we go through a ptm when we go
through an oma
our users can go onto the aoc web page
pull up the summary for the ri ptm they
can go to the journal
and pull up the oma article also so
great proof sources
data packages for our customers that
demonstrate the performance of dances
and we do work with certain companies
that have
certain a lot of them are larger
companies but they may have an internal
requirement that they will only use
aoc approved methods and we actually do
have some that require
that they will only use an oma method
what is the value of aoc certifications
to you so when you're looking for
when you're looking for an analytical
method
in your lab when you're looking for a
method or for any analyte that you have
or target that you have
if you go to a aoec and
consider those what have been approved
those methods may have
enhanced performance compared to others
on the market that have not gone through
a rigorous third party validation the
value also
is that rapid methods can be
validated a third party validation
it is independent as listed here which
is always important
aoc will validate all claims in the
package insert this is
especially important in the ptm process
which goes through
and you must validate any claim that you
have in your package incident
all test kit manufacturers must meet a
certain level of performance standard
and we talked about we brought the word
confidence before but this gives
the user confidence in the test kit
the analysis method that they are using
brand protection is is really important
in any industry it's going to be
important in the cannabis industry also
and again this goes back to confidence
you have confidence with aoc
approved methods these are third-party
rigorously validated methods so you can
have the confidence
that these methods will protect your
brand
and lastly i have noted here certificate
of analysis we do have customers that
will list
our aoc either ptm or oma methods on
their certificate
analysis to share with their customers
their laboratory customer how does an
aoec certification
influence lab validations so i think we
talked about this quite a bit but aoc
validation demonstrates the performance
in the rigor and the fit for purpose
of the method when these methods come
come out with aoec approved
bernice aoec approved certification or
ornoma
they're basically plug and play they're
ready to be moved into a laboratory
many times uh you know depending on what
the analyte is or the matrix is
if you have an aoec approval you can go
directly
into a lab with only verification so you
don't have to revalidate those on sites
you just do a simple
validation or verification iso
accreditation
these methods if they have an aoec can
help you during this process
to what extent you need to talk to your
accreditation
you know company that you're working
with but it can be benefit moving
forward
and then kind of an open question but an
interesting one is that houses going to
impact cannabis and state regulatory
acceptance
so our key takeaways aoc and cannabis
is the perfect collaboration this is an
emerging market
in working with aoec is going to be a
huge benefit for an emerging market
standardized testing collaboration with
experts
outside of cannabis it's just a a huge
benefit
we talked about smpr's quite a bit they
are going to be the yardstick moving
forward for new method comparison in
cannabis
and we see approvals benefit both the
test kit manufacturers and the users we
discussed this
and then lastly aoc is a fantastic
resource for the cannabis industry
moving forward
thank you for your attention please
reach out to aoec.org for
any information about the casp group or
any ptm approvals in
for cannabis and hemp you can also reach
out to me directly with any questions
thank you again